an analogy that the person runs and you
chase the person what she's cooking what
she's doing you see the energy curve
Cara is she's you're not doing the
geometry you're trying to make them look
like that chasing that particular shape
okay
say what you're doing is like you know
their body goes like that okay so you
are trying to make that shape you see
that whereas I go here not here and make
her go that way right
what happens is that I hear you wanting
to go about there you see that right and
he wants to go back you want to go back
and look at me this vid reconcile so now
I have to stay not over here
it's not that
next thing that happens sometimes you
change the geometry because this gets
heavy we see in a minute so you do not
find in the position pattern
the parks music
materials okay
so there's certain things you can't do
it the beginning so like that's going to
be like when you can't it's very
difficult so don't don't get there okay
so the closer you are to the bottom
leave your hardware is you see turn they
just want right and then don't move this
turn your body and then then this before
you get stuck and you try to hit this
turn your money don't over it it's going
to be harder for you okay it's not at
the beginning it's like no I'm trying to
learn those skills you get it so we're
trying to do two things at once
I'm trying to develop the internal
skills and time to learn an external
geometry for follow okay
I'm learning at the same time so one
wool you see how my body watch my body
one two turn
this don't kick me or you see his head
you're just a wait I don't want to dump
a barbell that is nice this rep I'm
going to do this I want to marvel it
does nothing
[Music]
so you are both training simultaneously
as you cannot get and you get you don't
want to let go and that's why you will
have on the choreography the
choreography is a fear response you get
it that's why we're doing it and that
you can't have these a nun reconcile
fear and try to be spontaneous is not
yet it doesn't work so this is a very
micro drill or you get on the sidewalk
psychological side is madness let go
don't have an intention okay try to be
just a bar
go over this okay now watch watch why we
do this geometry okay so the light part
is over here when you follow that hat
all that weight is working against you
and when you thinking as efficiency is
you're now requiring a greater straight
output for the movement of more force
and more mass you see and you follow the
head and so you can do the same thing
and you're going to follow the head pipe
long and go up your spine you see not
possible go till turn and go over the
hip so you're kind of setting yourself
up as you were picturing this is the
shape I want and so you're making the
head go where you want it to go and you
would always have your
and the failure why because it's gonna
require more force output capacity don't
do that so we're where do you feel it
that's not heavy that's how we don't
bother to get it okay so some of you are
now consciously I don't follow the head
don't follow him but I want you to do
instead is feel the weight on the head
angle that's telling you when to go to
the hip angle do you get it so it's not
I'm still not drawing a shape okay so
this arm heals there's the pattern
okay so you can be she goes you take
this statement Kimmy you see this is no
that's not anything we do here Hey so
the technique is called cookie wall
which means it should be conditioning
the fork off you confuse the utilization
the nominal utilisation of this body
organization
okay so this parts not it this part is
it okay now obviously the lightest line
is over these mouths that would be like
putting less weight on the barbell this
is both your home so what I want to try
to do is keep as much mass on the force
vector that's going to condition anymore
but I don't want to start conditioning
just an external you see that so what am
i conditioning the same thing I used
yesterday that the Kazushi pada that
he's using that I'm using on him
externally is happening internally in my
body so when I'm going here I don't push
my arm out I move my body
okay but you're not you're following
that yes and no one we only started what
this does in terms of the overall
geometry that this is not do you see so
when I'm moving look how my body's
changing animals with the same geometry
that I'm using to deviate changes change
the angle is the same one that's
positioning me right here it's gonna
take some hope to get back it's gonna
take some coordination I already know
how to do this I'm gonna do that my
whole life
like to move my body
so watch just watch my spine and watch
how much movement in order to move move
starting to rotate move move what I'm
doing is I'm saying that is easy up now
this is my movement
he comes in whatever
you're not gonna go like this you see
your mouth here
whoa
nobody should be here
because he hasn't shape he's making a
shape I am the other side of that mean
y'all simple okay you have your shape
he's over there
we are not in harmony hey we're not in
harmony I'm not in harmony here
every time but what do you think is
happening what's the lesson of
follow-through Zhongshan what actually
happens you stopped me before
you think you you disconnected Center
after and you didn't disconnect the
sender before just like people don't do
follow through or actually losing sight
alignment before the round went off
people that are not maintaining the
pressurized geometry in the deadlift
after the weight is off their hands have
actually broken that geometry wall the
waist okay
turn with your chest
Gong better when you are just turning
nothing's going over there so won't turn
boom when I told you to turn you went
like this
now you're actually disconnecting do you
see this connecting won't stop trying to
fix my conditioning and I can as as I go
I can't make him which is what you would
do normally as make him fall outside
this basic support
like that but I'll get more of prologue
cookie resistance pattern and if I've
been trying to make that thing move okay
so that instead of going here I try to
read that thing and that again
tactically that's going to be superior
was athletic people can readjust but
what we're doing is maybe this old base
not be under okay so if I can train cope
you pull that way I'm going to do one
condition
intact again I'm going to understand the
deconstruction of a base of support
versus just moving the line of gravity
outside of the base okay so let's try
the picture I'm painting the picture
there like he has to go
[Music]
find the same technologies it has to be
a yield and
[Applause]
don't lose this keep it there keep it
there this is not it this way do you
understand keep it there move out
can you hold my weight because this is
probably a little for you do you think
you got it
don't change it don't do this stop at
your level don't do this stuff keep here
you see that and then you do the
technique ok talk about the coordination
okay so you're here and you have to
release this okay keep this relationship
you have
and closed environment so you have to
maintain the prescribed energy okay you
just started to let energy out and she
went hey
I'm not
[Music]
yeah no energy
releasing that's happening inside my
farm in my heart it's not this
[Music]
okay so I have to let the bull get on
top of me yeah can't keep the ball out
it is off it is coming off the more it's
off than before I can throw it
so the in aspect is going to determine
how much young aspect you get got it
okay
[Music]
No
okay fine
it's very muchi and you should get a
little hopper do you hold it together
we're not that high it's not that fast
yeah you actually know
he pushes his nothing pushing back
how much capacity he's pushing on me see
I could do this in my externally but I
was going to try and talk to you then
just releasing releasing but not here
not here just releasing where he's
touching me
my 30-year lie I'm turning baby not
because I'm not an editor at this
Eastern Eastern
okay try it the problem is where the
case is and I'm gonna be dinner time it
is too early to go see so just keep a
singular intention and singular 10 don't
use the center pieces relax the chess
pieces
we're learning to feel my frictions what
you out
and you can feel the legend here it
doesn't matter
keep Elysium where you feel
and so the quality of the new game you
get the experiences are not so now no
more immediate go ahead and spend feel
it no this part has to say okay he goes
and you see see see see
every time
again
you're not making stuff you feel like I
gave him a college